so this is definitely the beginning of
you directing more movies because you
clearly know what you're doing so I am
I'm just going to start right from the
beginning uh are you already thinking
about what you want to do next is there
another genre that you want to play in
uh in terms of being behind the camera
yeah a little bit you know I'm playing
around with a couple a couple um genres
that that I like that I that interests
me
um not sure which way I want to go yet
but but there's a few are people already
offering you gigs phones ringed a couple
times which is which is like shocking
and and uh but but also you know you
know you know very humbling you know as
well and and you know what I guess the
work is speaking for itself so that's
pretty cool it's going to be interesting
for you because you are going to be
offered projects as an actor because
people want you to be acting in their
gigs and then also they want you
directing this had to have been a very
big challenge being obviously in front
of the camera doing boxing sequence I
mean you you bit off a lot the next time
that you direct will you put yourself on
camera in the movie or I'm not sure
about that I think that's that's that's
that's part of the like the thought
process is figuring out like where what
side of land line you want to stand on
you know and it is the project worth
doing both you know um just knowing what
it takes out of you you know like you
know this took a piece of me you know
and and all the best ways but you know
just to be able to take it from you know
pre-production to to this day to today
uh it's a lot in this Relentless and you
have to obsess over it and that's that's
all you can focus on so that level of
commitment only can come to a project
that it's worthy you know of that so so
I just gotta you know figure that out